bonsoir notre invité de ce soir est
l'homme l'un des hommes les plus connus
de france mais paradoxalement c'est
aussi l'un des plus mal connu c'est le
lot de tout ce qu'on voit partout de
ceux qui comme vous monsieur tapie ont
une apparence forte
on ne cherche pas toujours à savoir ceux
qui à l'intérieur on ne cherche pas
toujours à savoir ce qu'il ya derrière
le look
alors ce qui ne facilite pas les choses
c'est que vous pratiquez aussi le
mélange des genres vous êtes à vous seul
une sorte de trinité homme d'affaires à
la tête d'un groupe dont on ne perçoit
pas toujours la stratégie très
clairement président d'un club de
football prestigieux mais en conflit
avec les dirigeants du mouvement sportif
député des bouches du rhône depuis un an
mais quasiment absent du travail
parlementaire alors pour tout compliquer
vous êtes député de gauche et
milliardaire et en plus ça joue très
fier de l'être ce soir vous pourriez
être parfaitement assis à ma place
puisque je rappelle que la télévision
est une des cartes que vous avez dans
votre jeu alors aujourd'hui on a un peu
l'impression que votre centre de gravité
se déplace de des affaires et du sport
vers la politique vous vous êtes fait
élire à marseille dans une
circonscription qui était réputée
imprenable et vous avez terrasse et jean
marie le pen dans ce débat télévisé
alors avez-vous des recettes qui
pourraient être utiles à ceux dans la
politique et le métier que diriez vous
aujourd'hui aux électeurs de
villeurbanne qui sont déçus par l'offre
politique des partis traditionnels
est-ce qu'on peut inventer une nouvelle
politique et si oui avec qui ce sont là
des questions que brume de vous poser
alain duhamel jean marie colombani et
albert du roy et nous parlons bien sûr
aux sig
coupe du monde oblige nous parlons de
l'avenir du football professionnel mais
auparavant une première question de cp à
vous geneviève moll
bonsoir bernard tapie voici donc cette
première question qui nous vient des
verts au berner
quel est exactement votre credo
politique etes-vous socialiste
socialisant ou tout simplement
opportuniste
ça commence bien difficile
ça commence pas bien parce qu'en fait on
peut pas résumer ça en une demi minute
je suis pas socialiste puisque je suis
pas inscrit au parti socialiste et il
est difficile de dire je suis de gauche
parce qu'on sait plus très bien où se
trouve la frontière et qu'est-ce qui
délimite la droite de la gauche
on aura donc l'occasion probablement au
cours de cette soirée de définir ce que
c'est que pour moi la gauche ou la
droite
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que je me suis
inscrit sous une étiquette cette
étiquette c'est la majorité
présidentielle a été appelé comme ça à
l'époque
et c'est donc sous cette étiquette là
que j'ai débuté ma carrière politique
alors on verra si c'est compatible avec
ma situation sociale c'est compatible
avec les structures politiques actuelles
mais en fait je suis sans ambiguïté dans
la majorité présidentielle
on va voir ça tout à l'heure en
longuement avec alain duhamel pour un
quart d'heure pour s'envoyer tpiy alors
comme le disait françois henry vous
allez être interrogé forcément pendant
la soirée sur le football sur l'europe
sur l'économie sur l'industrie et cetera
c'est normal mais vous êtes aussi celui
qui est entré dans la bagarre politique
en disant lui-même en proclamant que
c'était pour stopper la montée en france
de l'extrême droite et du racisme alors
je voudrai savoir si il y à une méthode
tapis pour stopper la montée de
l'extrême droite en france
je crois qu a pas de méthode tapis tout
d'abord je pense objectivement quand on
fait référence à ce fameux débat
c'a été un peu le démarrage du tout en
tout cas pour ce qui concerne l'identité
qu'on a bien voulu me donner comme une
arme ou une des armes
je crois que je suis modeste mais je
suis obligé c'est pas forcément parce
que j'étais meilleur
c'est parce que je défends des des idées
plus facile à défendre et que quand on
défend les siennes il faut être
drôlement performant pour arriver à
l'emporter dans un débat démocratique et
républicain pour dire quelle est la
recette si vous le permettez et je
crains de prendre un peu sur votre temps
de pâques est urgent interrogé là-dessus
ici mais je suis obligé de faire allez-y
alors je considère tout d'abord qu'il
est bon parce que mon métier m'a appris
ça avant de parler de remède on commence
par faire un diagnostic et avant de
faire un diagnostic on fait nos dit
qu'est ce que c'est le front national
qu'en fait le pen ne m'intéresse que par
rapport au front national
pour être simple et schématique giresse
est une espèce de grosse voiture balai
c'est au tour de france la voiture balai
c'est celle qui ramassent tous ceux qui
au cours de l'étape abandonne sont
blessés sont malades veulent plus qu'on
dit mais plus les taper dur plus la
voiture d'à ballet plein en général
l'étape paris versailles à personne mais
dans l'étape de l'alpe d'huez
la voiture me laisse remplit donc c'est
une espèce de voiture balai qui va dans
cette société française récolté petit à
petit des couches de gens très
différents dont les motifs sont très
différents même parfois opposés et qui
vont venir est de construire l'espèce de
mille feuilles qui va être l'électorat
l'open la base vers la la croûte
c'est pas par hasard s'il appelle comme
ça c'est quand même des gens qui sont
fondamentalement d'extrême droite ont
toujours été il était touché vignancour
ils sont de villepin ils sont racistes
ils sont antisémites ils sont fascistes
et pourquoi ça montre maintenant ils
sont 2 3 4%
ils sont six je sais pas combien ils
sont mais n'empêche qu'ils sont pas les
15 20 à 25% dans ta première couche qui
vient se greffer sur ce fonds de
commerce acquis tout ce qui est
objectivement et subjectivement souffre
à tort ou à raison ou croit souffrir de
l'immigration hier tous ceux qui à un
moment donné sont confrontés à une
coexistence un mal de vivre avec les
autres
cela le pen ayant pris le parti pris de
défendre les français les petits blancs
contre les immigrés c'est un fonds de
commerce qui se développe
ça représente la première couche
deuxième couche c'est une couche qui
dans une société un peu un peu cynique
un peu performante un peu difficile pour
les minorités ou pour les faibles laisse
sur le bord de la route un tas de gens
justement la voiture balai là pour les
ramasser comment aller en masse parce
qu'on dit des choses on lance des
musiques qui sont agréables entendre ce
formidable de dire un handicapé c'est
scandaleux
qu'on touche pas et qu'on fasse pas en
sorte que les handicapés soient pas pris
en considération
c'est honteux que les chômeurs soient
chômeurs c'est pas dur ce sont des
musiques agréable à entendre
alors là on ramasse et on continue et on
avance 4e catégorie
ce sont ceux qui fondamentalement sont
de droite et ne supporte pas les gens de
gauche il ne vole plus que la gauche au
pouvoir et il estime que les dirigeants
de droite actuels classique
giscard sont pas capables de battre la
droite à gauche et il pense que le pen
va y arriver alors cela viennent grossir
les rangs et la dernière catégorie
ceux qui sont contre les partis qui sont
le dont la femme est partie avec le
voisin dont les institutions les
emmerdes qui disent moi je fais un
pied-de-nez aux institutions classiques
aux partis politiques classiques et je
vote le pen alors quand on a fait
l'inventaire et qu'on a su que
finalement c'est ça l'électorat de
l'open alors on propose des solutions
alors il ya des solutions et monsieur
duhamel je vais vous dire j'ai rarement
à la télévision
lancer des défis ou pris les paris que
j'ai pas tenu jeudi rarement mais sait
jamais je vous certifie je vous affirme
pour les avoir testés moi même que si on
applique les méthodes que je vais vous
suggérer dans moins de 18 mois le front
national est réduit à moins de 10% dans
moins de 18 mois
dix-huit mois moins de 10 % - 2 on est
d'accord moins de 18 mois et -2 -2 18
mois - des bourses pour ça qu'elle
régional devrait vous rappeler
simplement que quand je suis rentré en
politique pour la première fois la
question qui se pose est celle qui de
godin ou de le pen sera maire de
marseille il avait déclaré dimanche la
tonitruante
c'est une grande histoire d'amour qui
naît et qui commence entre marseille et
moi le pen avait fait aux
présidentielles à marseille 29 % ma
circonscription
aux dernières législatives alors qu'il
n'a pas cessé de monter
le candidat du front national a fait
moins de 10% il n'a pas pu se maintenir
au deuxième tour
high tech 3 est plat et magie et
peut-être ma boucle peines et j'ai parlé
aux gens on a discuté aux gens avec eux
je suis allé sur place dans les
immeubles j'ai fait du porte à porte
je leur ai parlé
alors la solution comment on va arriver
10% c'est un chiffre lamentable et 18
mois c'est court et c'est pas tout seul
que je peux y arriver et c'est pas un
homme qui sort une solution d'un chapeau
alors il ya trois axes de travail qu'il
faut absolument à coupler le premier
l'état a pris des décisions à la pris
des dispositions qui sont de nature à
éviter que les migrations progressé que
les immigrés soient qu'ils soient là
soit intégrée sur le plan local il ya
tous les élus locaux les conseils
généraux les conseils régionaux les
mères qui travaillent d'arrache-pied s
et trouver des solutions parce qu'il y a
identifié entre 350 et 400 points bien
connue bien identifiés qui sont des
points de friction et de cohabitation
difficile
ces points conflictuels il faut
impérativement les travailler
individuellement on va donc créer à
partir du 1er septembre
on sait qu'ils ont c'est à dire tous
ceux qui vont se reconnaître à l'instant
ceux qui ne veulent pas prendre le
risque que par une abstention excessive
un jour comme alibi villeurbanne le pen
soit président de la république car je
crois pas que jamais il y aura 51% des
français qui voteront l'open selon ce
que je crains c'est qu'à force de
considérer qu'il n'aura jamais 51 bon
sens il y aura peut-être un jour 51 %
des gens qui votent comme c'est le cas
en ce moment les villes aux rebelles
alors si tout ce qui vole pas que ça
arrive ils ont envie de se lever le
derrière
je leur propose à partir du 1er
septembre concret le forum des citoyens
et qu'on travaille qu'on soit avocat udf
qu'on soit médecin et repère conçoit
mécano socialiste où qu'on soit
cantonniers communiste qu'on travaille à
identifier d'abord quels sont les
problèmes posés dans ses 350 points
qu'on fasse ce que j'apprends à faire
dans mon métier
quel est le problème posé alors ça c'est
vous qui allez en prendre la tête de ce
forum des citoyens tout à fait et vous
avez vous aurez les gens qu'il faut les
moyens qu'il faut j'ai commencé par
créer je voudrais pas que vous fassiez
perdre le fil parce que c'est très
important
l'annoncé faisait encore deux points
d'ailleurs porter moi le crédit ces
accords et de que j'avais arriver à les
mobiliser
le deuxième point il faut impérativement
que les partis politiques qui sont
actuellement très critique et qui sont
actuellement parait-il
le centre du débat de la population de
la société tout entière est ce qu'ils
sont bons à ce qu'ils sont pas bons est
ce qu'ils sont et metz qui sont pas être
le problème ils correspondent plus aux
besoins des gens d'aujourd'hui il faut
impérativement qu'ils comprennent que la
démocratie dépend de leur capacité à
s'adapter aux besoins des gens de demain
ça veut dire quoi se retrouver de
nouveau des points de repère moi quand
je disais quand j'étais jeune je suis à
gauche ça voulait dire par rapport à une
ligne qui était clair qui était indiqué
il ya une ligne la gauche il ya trois
mois la droite la droite c'était le
capitalisme avec des exemples des
valeurs des symboles et aujourd'hui la
gauche avant si vous voulez bien c'était
le marxisme à des degrés différents à
des applications différentes salles est
de l'extrême gauche sociale des bras si
la droite capitaliste
ça allait de faut prendre en
considération les problèmes des gens à
il est noir finalement il n'est pas
digne d'être des nôtres
il y avait toutes ses sensibilités d'un
seul coup deux événements majeurs sont
arrivés il faut par les uns parce que
sinon on peut pas comprendre pourquoi
les partis sont dans cet état
le premier événement majeur la gauche
revient au pouvoir la gauche qui était
le symbole d'une générosité d'une utopie
de la rêverie des gens en fait
conducteurs en opposition à la droite
qui sont gestionnaire rigoureux organisé
le faut bien le dire un peu
individualiste intégrisme on se retrouve
avec une gauche qui pendant deux ans
pilote le pays comme ils pensent qu'il
faut le piloter en leur âme et
conscience
ça voulait dire 80 83 et je vous raconte
pas comment l'avion nombre des places se
rappelle on se rappelle les dures
réalités de l'économie mondiale les
dures réalités de l'apprentissage du
pouvoir fait que la gauche se rend
compte qu'on peut pas complètement faire
comme on le disait quand on n'était pas
au pouvoir et que cette façon de gérer
parce qu'on y est obligé amène aux
manettes des ministres qui deviennent
bérégovoy un des meilleurs ministres des
finances du monde avec des règles qui
correspondent pas tout à fait aux règles
de l'opposition et est ce que vous direz
que ça des meilleurs ministres des
finances de l'ue
du monde fin des meilleurs ministres
d'humour et en plus complètement de
gauche et sincèrement de ce premier
événement donc qui amène les socialistes
au pouvoir fait perdre un peu les
repères à ceux qui avaient cru à une
société dans laquelle on parlait pas de
rigueur
vous parlez pas d'austérité ont parlé au
contraire de distribution ils ont fait
les frais
quand on donne des assignats on rend les
gens plus malheureux à terre car quand
il faut payer faut payer en vraie
monnaie est pas en monnaie de singe et
alors la droite dans ce temps là elle
qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle continue de
gérer en opposant en disant parce qu'ils
ont plus de discours qui fait la
promotion du capitalisme puisqu'on est
en train de gérer comme des libéraux
alors à l'étape de lentilles gauche
complètement prière à partir de là
essayons d'accepter l'idée que les gens
comprennent plus bien où se trouve la
gauche et la droite vient se greffer sur
ces événements une catastrophe
le marxisme c'est sûr ça marche pas vous
l'aidiez l'effondrement alors la balle
ça marche pas et maintenant il ya toute
personne qui peut soutenir que ça marche
alors ça fait beaucoup pour maintenir
d'un côté la gauche d'artistes de
l'autre côté la droite capitaliste
ça devient quoi le pays grâce à une
propagande à une promotion grâce à
phénoménal j'irai une phénomène à
l'utilisation de le pen de la
circonstance présente on va définir la
france avec une nouvelle frontière
il ya les racistes d'un côté et les
antiracistes l'hôte d'un seul coup on se
retrouve divisé en deux c'est plus la
gauche et à droite c'est et raciste août
et antiracistes et ça ça vous paraît une
bonne frontières ça ça me paraît une
mare est réaliste ça me parait
monstrueux d'abord parce que le nombre
de raciste en france est pas
suffisamment important pour faire un
côté de la france et d'autre part parce
que j'aimerais qu'on replace le débat
politique et les partis ont le devoir de
le replacer la houle est alors il est où
mais il est qu'on a admis maintenant une
fois pour toutes que la france un pays
capitaliste qui est géré selon des modes
de gestion libérale
ça veut pas dire qu'on gère pareil et ça
veut pas dire qu'on pense la même chose
et ça veut dire que dans cette
définition là moi je me
à sa gauche quand même et pas forcément
parce que j'ai du coeur parce que si je
dois maintenant synthétiser ces deux
valeurs j'insiste parce que c'est très
important ça ça je comprends rien à la
politique et les gens vont rien
comprendre à la politique de demain ça
veut dire d'accord on est sous les
menaces ou on est sous l'influencé du
marché
mais le marché on en fait deux choses
possibles le 1er au 10 axa qui compte
est mort aux cons c'est un peu ce que me
propose monsieur chirac ce chirac il n'a
pas compris que ça marchait pas car son
système c'est à de chair c'est les états
unis ça peut pas fonctionner puis à
l'autre système
l'autre système qui consiste à dire je
vais prendre en considération les moins
bons et je ne peux prendre comme exemple
la valeur individuelle que si elle est
compatible avec l'intérêt collectif et
là ça marche pas seulement parce qu'on a
du coeur ça marche parce que monsieur
duhamel
quand on prend en considération tout le
monde ça marche beaucoup mieux que quand
on les prend pas en compte donc et à
partir du moment la deuxième définition
c'est la classe politique qui se change
et qui dit aux gens voilà ce que c'est
la droite
voilà ce que c'est la gauche si vous
voulez des l'autre voilà où on veut vous
amener où la société doit conduire si je
suis bien votre raisonnement ça signifie
que dans votre idée par exemple les
partis de gauche vont dire nous c'est le
marché mais la générosité mais la
solidarité la générosité la solidarité
et et que les partis de droite vont dire
nous tous les pauvres les laissés pour
compte les malheureux ils disent on les
laisse de côté un qui disent la droite
dit la performance avant tout parce que
quand on est performant on crée des
richesses et quand on a créé les
richesse on peut les distribuer sa part
toujours d'un sentiments généreux aussi
je ne connais pas un homme de droite qui
dit je suis content que les gens qui
sont au chômage et je suis content
qu'elle ait qui meurent de faim c'est ce
que je voulais bien sûr je suis
simplement en train de dire c'est pas
dans ce sens là que ça se passe
c'est en prenant en considération
d'abord ceux qui sont tout en bas qu'on
arrive à faire que la société tout
entière marche les cercles de qualité
les hommes qui dans une entreprise sont
chargés de faire les relations sociales
sont pas des hommes qui a tout
simplement à terme c'est eux qui rendent
la société voulait pas laisser finir la
troisième manche
pourquoi theron plus dans la merde
reconnaissez que je vous ai pas
interrompre iskandar toujours que
laisser le sud via mail que c'est le
plus important de l'année
écoutez si c'était sans intérêt je vous
aurais je voudrais vous dire simple vous
reste la troisième fois ci il n'y a
qu'une chose qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui
la politique c'est d'essayer à mon
niveau et avec tout ce qu'ils volent
d'essayer de remédier à ce problème là
et sans quitter votre métier et sans
quitter le mien parce que c'est pas
c'est pas nécessaire et en plus de ça je
crois donc je garderai cette possibilité
d'être libre de ne pas vivre de ça je
garderai ma liberté alors avec la
troisième oui parce que nous aurons un
stand pour l'instant en 2020 avec votre
forum vous mobiliser des gens de l'est
par ailleurs plat rôles diagnostic on
est alors 3 comme j'ai fait avec les
écoles de formation pour les jeunes
chômeurs 1 elle déclarait marc andreu 3
on peut plus laisser sous sous prétexte
que d'être nationaliste ça peut plus
être d'actualité et que c'est ringard on
peut plus laisser le monopole du drapeau
français du patriotisme à le pen
sous-entendu et on l'a fait lors diana à
brigue
ah oui maintenant on a l'impression que
il y en a qu'un seul qui défend la
française drapeau activision ce pays
parce que ce pays il est fabuleux
il n'y a plus que lui d'après ce que
j'entends qu'à droit de le dire or il ya
une ambiguïté épouvantable c'est que je
connais pas un homme au monde qui dit
autant de mal de la france et les
français que lui il est sans arrêt en
train de nous donner en exemple les
autres de nous dire qu'on est des torts
du conte et des ratés qu'on était moins
que rien et prétend aimer la france
or je crois que là les français surtout
au moment où leur part iv on en parlera
sûrement ils ont un besoin phénoménal de
se retrouver de nouveau avec l' envie
d'aimer quelque chose et kate ya c'est
que cette social veut dire une identité
complètement une vraie cette société qui
est banalisante donne envie à chacun de
se singulariser
mais moi ce qui me fait plaisir c'est
quand finalement se retrouve à aimer de
nouveau la france parce que quand on
fait comme je fais deux fois plus de
kilomètres par an qu'un pilote d'air
france bien chaque fois que je rentre
ici je suis heureux d'y revenir parce
que c'est là qu'on y vit le mieux et
c'est un des pays qui est à mon avis
le plus beau du monde c'est pas de la
démarrer on peut pas laisser ce terrain
là une entrevue le pen qui finalement je
crois pas qu'ils aiment puisqu'il était
un de ceux qui étaient prêts à livrer la
france à l'allemagne et l heure actuelle
mais pas vraiment puisque françois
arrive à me demander de regagner ma
place
sinon maintenant 6 6 il a compris que
vous n'aviez pas pu faire bouffer mais
enfin quand même normal moi je le
connais je connais bien vous pensez que
tout ce que vous venez d'expliquer la
com métamorphose et 3 métamorphose que
vous venez de décrire vous pensez que
vous pouvez arriver à les réaliser et à
les faire réaliser à inciter les autres
à les réaliser tout ça en 18 mois
je suis absolument celui pourquoi en 18
mois parce que comment on dit j'aimerais
en 24 mois 24 mois c'est à dire quatre
mois après il ya des élections
importantes qui seront un point de
repère
ah oui mais ça ça veut dire que ce
serait ça ça veut dire que ce serait
souhaitable que ce soit fait dans les
deux ans mais ça va pas forcément dire
ça que ces prairies bleues l'année ça
sera fait monsieur ça sera fait c'est
pas la méthode coué je suis pas très
partisan de la méthode coué si vous
voulez tout à l'heure au cours des
questions pour vos collègues que vous
poseront les chalets et pris un
engagement que je n'ai tenu
d'accord ce que je crois que la méthode
coué ça fait pas tellement avancé alors
je laisse les autres bercy regrette
qu'on ait mairie signale à rieumes airs
d'autrefois
une autre fois on reposera découvrir en
effet si je peux bien faire 2-3
il a été très sportif merci merci alain
duhamel voulais te dire voulait dire
venez de répéter plusieurs fois jeune et
j'ai rarement pris un engagement que je
n'ai pas tenus ya une question qui nous
est très souvent posées par les
associations d'handicapés
c'est l'engagement que vous avez pris
lors de votre émission sur tf1 plus fort
la vie je croise était de d'embauché
dans le groupe bernard tapie des
handicapés est ce que vous pouvez ce
soir donné des précisions sur le nombre
d'handicapés que vous avez embauché
maintenant gâcher une trentaine depuis
ses missions mais c'est pas significatif
parce que par rapport au nombre
d'employés
ça fait un pourcentage qui est bien trop
réduit mais c'est qu'est ce que je
voulais dire par-là
je voulais dire de la même manière que
lorsque j'ai engagé un combat contre le
chômage des jeunes sans formation
on s'est donné les moyens on en a fait
une première maintenant on est à la
huitième écoles on en forme mille par an
fondée le 15 les écoles les handicapés
c'est pas compliqué j'ai essayé au cours
de cette émission grâce à une leçon
de courage inouï qui nous ont donné
inouï ils nous ont tous remis la tête
d'aplomb j'ai essayé de faire comprendre
aux gens que c'était un plus de les
avoir et nous on est en train de faire
les tests et les deux premiers tests
qu'on a fait sur des carrières
commerciales
c'est époustouflant de résultats sont
des gens qui parce que justement ils ont
connu la souffrance vrai par la
souffrance psychologique
la vraie souffrance dans leur chair ils
sont devenus à un moment donné des gens
qui se posaient des questions sur leur
propre existence
lorsqu'on a la chance de leur donner
lorsqu'ils ont la chance d'avoir un
boulot ils sont comme personne d'autre
tellement ils ont envie de démontrer
qu'on habite d'accord mais le coeur la
pédagogie c'est une chose l'énergie pour
gaza dans une eau non leur engagement
sanaa alors goûter donc vous vous
estimez que vous avez tenu vos
engagements
mais c'est pas le problème je n'ai pas à
me justifier de sa j'aurais tenu mes
engagements le jour j'aurai le sentiment
qu'ils appuient handicap etc est traité
comme un handicapé parce que dans les
handicaps et il ya des feignants il ya
des mauvais il ya des atouts mais il
faut pas que le handicapé qui est pas
comme ça soit prêté autrement un hockey
autant d'années coeur etc
vous m'avez jamais entendu parler de ça
j'ai jamais parlé de coeur mais jamais
vous savez pourquoi
parce que c'est une notion sur laquelle
j'avais ce type à dans le temps j'ai
jamais cru que le coeur était tout un
mode de gestion des hommes
je crois qu'il est laissé à la
disposition de chacun et à personne qui
a le droit de dire de ce côté là ils ont
nom de ce côté là ils en ont pas je
connais des salopards tout je connais
des gens formidables partout ok on
retourne à svp questions des
téléspectateurs geneviève moll 1 à tapis
vous êtes très médiatique et très
médiatisée avec aviez vous besoin d'être
débuté pour faire passer votre message
de temps qu'on vous voit peu et qu on
vous entend peu à l'assemblée on voit
pas beaucoup et on voit pas beaucoup
parce que je considère que c'est
important d'y être on voit pas beaucoup
parce que j'ai pas beaucoup le temps d'y
être quand je me suis fait élire député
je me suis fait élire avec un contrat
clair avec les électeurs c est ce que je
peux quelque part d'abord traiter les
problèmes de coexistence et d'existence
journalières et là je les fais y avait
2-3 problèmes ponctuels qui était il n'y
avait pas d'école de formation il y
avait un problème de télévision c'est
tout con mais il y avait 5000 personnes
qui recevaient pas la télévision
dans ma circonscription parce qu'elle
avait une montagne qui gênait l'émetteur
va donc y avait un premier travail et
comptait sur moi pour ça ce que leur vie
de tous les jours qu'on met compter
aussi sur moi pour autre chose
est-ce que nous qui sommes électeurs de
la 6e circonscription de marseille
on est fier de l'avoir comme député si
en étant invité dans des émissions comme
celle-là et 6 ans n'ayant développer les
idées qu'à la fin de cette émission les
gens se seront fait sur moi
il en tire de la fierté et qu'ils disent
finalement on est content qu'il soit
notre député je serai le député qu'ils
attendaient si à la fin ils ont honte
parce que ma prestation et lamentable
parce que j'ai pas su faire avancer les
idées que je défends
eh bien ils auront raison fumée lire
mais c'est pas d'être présent sur un
banc dans lequel de temps en temps je
sers pas grand chose qui fera qui me
kimeli rompt pas cela dit je considère
que le député qui ne fait que ça son
devoir c'est d'être présent le plus
souvent possible à l'assemblée car c'est
tout de même là que le destin du pays et
le destin des gens se fait là que se
font les lois quand même on va enchaîner
avec jean marie colombani pour un quart
d'heure bonsoir aussi dit tout à l'heure
j'ai compris de ce que vous répondiez
alain duhamel que vous vous étiez
farouchement anti raciste alors je
voudrais demander au président de
l'olympique de marseille comment il
réagit c'est à dire comment ils jugent
mais aussi comment ils essayent de faire
face aux réactions ouvertement raciste
d'une partie du public marseillais
notamment lorsque des joueurs d'origine
camerounaise pénètrent sur la pelouse du
stade vélodrome
oui il s'agit de joseph antoine bell
entre autres qu'est-ce que je suis
content que vous posiez cette question
je suis sûr qu'on approche je vous ai
demandé de la pause et vous savez ce que
c'est ne pas être raciste c'est de dire
qu'un homme est un escroc même quand il
est noir par exemple la réaction du
public sur monsieur bell n'a rien à voir
avec la couleur sa peau elle est que
pendant deux ans c'est à dire depuis le
jour où il étudia le but de l'olympique
de marseille il n'a cessé de donner sur
marseille et sur le club
une image négative il n'a cessé de dire
parce que c'était probablement la façon
qu'il ressentait il n'a cessé de dire
qu'on n'était pas un grand club on était
une équipe il n'a cessé de dire qu'à
marseille on y vivait pas bien avec les
supporters qui débordait dans leur
présence auprès des joueurs donc lors la
première partie de cette réponse jours
et vous le sachiez
c'est que ce n'était pas parce qu'il
était noir c'est parce que il avait
pendant plusieurs mois
dépasser ce qu'on peut tolérer un joueur
qui n'est plus dans cette équipe on le
fait quand même des bananes dans les
poches alors acheter son disque mais il
ya comme on manifeste mécontentement et
là lorsqu'on a appris qu'ils avaient
l'intention de le manifester de la
manière la plus nulle la plus lamentable
c'est à dire en prenant la couleur de sa
peau comme prétexte on a fait notre
devoir c'est à dire qu'on a fait des
fouilles on a interdit un certain nombre
d'accessoires de pénétrer sur le stade
et puis finalement ça s'est déroulé avec
très peu de tri mais les supporters de
l'olympique de marseille le savent car
dans mes éditoriaux que je fais dans mon
petit journal mensuel
je ne cesse de dire le jour où j'aurai
le sentiment qu'on peut plus à verser ce
système je ne serai plus président de la
pilule minceur
alors les cris d'hostilité ont cessé et
de temps en temps ça a été
ponctuellement retrouver au moment de
belles mais je vous prie de croire que
si un endroit à marseille où jamais il
n'y a justement ces manifestations
insupportable et où il ya une espèce de
communion autour d'un projet commun
c'est au stade
partout ailleurs c'est pas le caméo
statique en restant un petit peu sur le
football et sur l'om
en deux mots vous étiez fixé un objectif
précis qui était gagné une coupe
d'europe
vous l'avez pas gagnée est ce que vous
considérez que le jeu en valait la
chandelle
par exemple est ce que vous considérez
que vous avez eu raison de d'agir comme
vous avez agi en récoltant derrière vous
l'image dans le football français je
caricature mais enfin c'est ce sont des
choses qu'on entend l'image de l'homme
qui au fond a remplacé le bénévolat par
l'affairisme
est-ce que donc le jeu en valait la
chandelle le bénévolat par la fei ce
qu'on entend dire j'ai vraiment pensé
voilà non c'est vrai que ça sonne moins
bien un ferry smac bénévolat non ne
dites pas que vous l'avez jamais entendu
dire mais est large et le 10 ans lorsque
la violation de l'affairisme ne l'avait
pas entendu mais enfin c'est le discours
des officiels du footballeur c'est moi
j'ai pas j'ai pas je veux dire que j'ai
pas à savoir si ce serait mieux qu'on
continue des associations - le 101 qui
depuis 30 ans gagnent pas de coupe
d'europe c'est à dire ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas vous qui allez jamais au stade
car je suis sûr vous allez jamais au
stade vous trompez ce tapis c'est
dommage pour vous mais je me suis lui
j'allais pas le dire parce que je vous
ai vu vous je vous ai jamais mais moi je
suis un ardent je vais vous faire une
confidence ça intéresse personne
d'ailleurs si bien sûr on sait jamais
rien ne vous suis un ardent supporters
de bastia qui est arrivé en finale d'une
coupe d'europe
sansan affairisme je dire si
complètement non double licence en chose
grandiloquente mais plein de formes
scéniques rappelaient de l'année mais à
l'époque je vais vous dire les bastiais
d'origine ces terres est un des
meilleurs joueurs de hollande comme s'il
n'y avait que des plus importe c'est un
des plus gros budgets
alors vous pouvez maintenant mais piqué
attendez laissez moi non non non non
comme ça vous allez pouvoir me dire par
où commencer avec un déficit non vous
êtes en train de me dire que bastia ça
finit avec un énorme déficit est en
faillite
bon parce que prendre des vedettes c'est
peut-être critiquable mais ce qui est
plus critiquable c'est de les prendre
sans savoir comment on va les payer
c'est pas le point le point c'est de
savoir se verrait considérer si vous
considérez que il faut au football
français dont pour être à niveau des
structures radicalement différente de
celle qui existe aujourd'hui dans les
clubs français c'est ça le gros nerf moi
on est dans un moment où les points de
repère des pays les uns pas pour les
autres sont très difficiles à faire et
où le petit peuple
le tout petit qui comprend pas ce que
c'est que le pib c'est parce que c'est
avec la croissance mais qui sait que en
ce moment ils regardent la télé et il
voit les émirats y voit la colombie y
voit le cameroun est il dit pardon j'ai
pas vu l'équipe de france et celui-là
c'est une petite partie de bonheur qui
l'a pas et qu'il aimerait avoir
alors on peut dire ça n'a aucune
importance
et on continue dans le bénévolat avec
des associations doit 901 moi j'ai dit
si c'est ça que vous voulez on peut le
faire on sera jamais champion d'europe
si vous voulez autre chose il va falloir
qu'on dépense beaucoup d'argent
je veux bien faire le fonds de roulement
moi même et faire à marseille l'une des
plus grandes équipes qui ait jamais eu
et le fait est que cette équipe allait
reconnue comme une des plus grandes
elle fait des records de recettes par
tous elle est arrivée en demi-finale de
coupe d'europe
éliminés je vous dis pas comment
mais en tout cas elle est maintenant
déjà dès la troisième année une des plus
grandes équipes d'europe
et quand je sais que 18 pays ont acheté
les droits télévision de cette équipe et
qu'on a reconnu
on a battu les records d'audience ça
veut dire que plein de gens ce soir là
juste ce soir là pendant une heure et
demie sont égalés alors la question
c'est de savoir est ce que c'est ça
qu'il faut faire
moi la seule question que je me suis
posée monsieur colle au mali c est ce
que j'ai les moyens de le faire et
est-ce que s'il football français tout
entier le fait pas vous percez six mois
personnage vote les six personnes 800
millions de caution personnelle doit
aussi aux suédois de convois vous n'êtes
pas dans le milieu des désaccords soient
pas beaucoup d'écart entre la caution
personnelle et le chèque vacances à
l'avant vous payez la bande qui donne
les 100 millions surtout elle peut
donner 200 du monde qu'elle sait que je
les payais un jour c'est pas pareil que
la caution de la mairie d'accord si oui
est ce que je veux dire
alors ma caution personnelle elle est à
la hauteur des besoins du club la
question qui est importante
est-ce que laval est ce que strasbourg
où est-ce que encore strasbourg c'est
une grande scène
est-ce que auxerre y trouvera un moment
donc le spectateur son compte
moi je vois qu'une chose auxerre juillet
donnait plus de 35 millions de francs en
deux ans pour lui acheter des joueurs
qu'ils ont formés sur vos pages existe
mais d'accord drôlement content quand
j'y arrive je vais aller record dans
cette je remplis les cas le destin des
petits clubs c'est de vous vendre les
meilleurs joueurs et d'être obligée de
leur silence au fur et à lie puisque
tous les journalistes français sont
unanimes à reconnaître que ce serait
formidable si le football était aussi
attrayant 8 à y quand je vois monsieur
de virieu parc des princes il me dit
quel dommage qu'on n'ait pas la turin où
la juve ou milan on peut les avoir
on a les moyens quand on se la donne on
est aussi bon que les italiens en
cyclisme pourrais vous dire qu'on a le
même statut professionnel que les autres
nos cyclistes sont si bons que les
autres dans le monde entier donc le
football peut pas à la fois être
compétitif par rapport aux italiens
s'ils se donnent pas les mêmes moyens
la seule question est ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse comme eux si la réponse
c'est non on s'en fout alors on reste au
niveau des associations
mais alors moi si la réponse est oui
je veux qu'on ait des grands clubs
européens il faut faire pareil peut
alors vous voyez quelque chose juste une
un dernier mot sur le football c'est que
j'aimerais comprendre c'est pourquoi
autour de vous il ya tous ept
on s'est un peu cette odeur de soufre
l'a récemment vous même vous avez pris
une initiative un peu spectaculaire vous
avez sollicité le ministre du budget
michel charasse lui même en lui donnant
des documents sur le coup de grâce est
bon j'ai lu les avions après
alors voilà alors est ce que c'est vrai
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ces documents si
c'est vrai qu'ils aient visé est
pourquoi au fond michel charasse ne vous
répond si c'est pas vrai pour que vous
l'avez pas démenti c'est quand même deux
mois que le soir même alors je vais vous
dire je voyais monsieur charasse pour
trois raisons la première c'est qu'il me
semble que le statut fiscal des joueurs
professionnels et pas adapté parce
qu'ils ont une carrière trop court il
faudra qu'ils payent l'impôt sur une
période plus longue la deuxième c'est
qu'actuellement il ya des contrôles
fiscaux qui ont été décidées sur les
joueurs plus d'un an sur les clubs et
beaucoup de présidents m'appelait il en
est pour me dire ça va être
catastrophique parce qu'il ya tellement
de flou dans les règlements c'est vrai
qu'on a choisis toujours le parti pris
le plus intéressant pour mon club il
risque donc d'y avoir des conséquences
graves
est ce que tu peux faire quelque chose
je voulais donc lamballe troisième
rennes je sais maintenant le seul moyen
vrai qu'un club peut éventuellement
utilisés pour sortir de l'argent de son
club et pour se le mettre dans la poche
et mon devoir était de lui dire fois la
cia d enrichissement personnel c'est
comme ça qui se fait mais pour répondre
à votre question et pour répondre je
dirais presque à mes collègues
présidents des autres clubs
j'incite les journalistes sportifs
interrogés charasse qui est un ministre
on ne peut plus franc qui dit toujours
la vérité toujours et si on leur
demandait si vos collègues lourdes lui
demanda lui qui a déclenché les
contrôles fiscaux des clubs et de la
ligue
il risque d'y avoir beaucoup de
surprises sur l'identité de celui qui
les a demandé en tout cas c'est pas moi
qui les ai demandé et je voudrais savoir
quelle tête feront les clubs
le jour où ils sauront qui a demandé les
contrôles fiscaux mais comme c'est pas
mon métier de dévoiler ce genre de
choses je demande aux journalistes
d'interroger charasse ça il a toujours
appelé un chat un chat lui vice
président puis te dira je sais pas si
vous le ferez on va
précipitez demain chez michel charasse
mais en attendant je voudrais vous
demander si le sport pour vous au fond
des choses
si le sport c'est autre chose pour vous
que l'image du sport mise au service
d'une ambition qui n'est pas sportive
qui n'est pas seulement sportive mais
qui peut être par exemple politique
leclerc a voulu savoir si c'était ça le
sport il a été champion de france
il a gagné la coupe de france et s'est
présenté aux mêmes élections que moi il
a fait 2 % mais parce que je vais vous
dire quelque il faut rappeler peut-être
qui était celle de claire anciens
étaient dans l ancien président de
l'olympique de bischwiller nous
expliquer défraya la chronique en sont
et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
car une des difficultés aujourd'hui
majeurs de la classe politique c'est que
les gens sont devenus très intelligent à
8h35 figurez vous qu'ils savent 90% de
choses que président de la république
c'est et l'histoire des marionnettes ou
le bentô vous pouvez plus la leur faire
donc si vous les croyez à ses sauts pour
vous faire une image politique parce que
vous remplissez un stade et que vous
marquez deux bus à auxerre vous les
prenez pour beaucoup plus haut qu'ils ne
sont
les gens s'affairent l'écart simon
confié à un moment donné un mandat
politique
les trois quarts d'entre eux s'en
foutent complètement de savoir les
résultats de l'olympique de marseille
alors partant de là moi j'ai une analyse
où je respecte plus les gens donc je les
prends pas pour des imbéciles donc ne
croyez pas à aucun moment que celui qui
peut croire que parce qu'il va faire des
résultats
dans le football il va arriver sur
l'autoroute du sud pour faire une
carrière politique ça se passe pas comme
ça figure aime bien alors votre
autoroutes du sud à vous en termes
politiques c'est quoi
vous avez dit bon vous êtes député un
moment vous accrue tenté par la mairie
de marseille
vous pourriez l'être à nouveau est ce
que vous l'êtes ce que vous le serez un
jour est-ce que vous n'êtes pas plutôt
tenté par la région provence alpes côte
d'azur et si oui pourquoi
et puis j'aimerais aussi savoir si vous
aimeriez être ministre ministre de la
population par exemple alors être
ministre non j'aimerais pas pour deux
raisons la première c'est que ces temps
complet ah oui et la deuxième c'est que
je suis pas sûr que j'apporterai
beaucoup en étant ministre parce que là
alors ça me coupe toute ma liberté
d'expression de 2,2 l'an gaz d'attitude
on est obligé de se référer à un patron
j'ai pas de patron pour l'instant et je
me réjouis j'ai pas envie d'en avoir
ensuite si quelque part je crois que la
proportion de ceux qui font la classe
politique est trop importante
du côté de ceux qui sortent de la même
école je crois que les énarques ou les
polytechniciens sont des gens taupe un
rôle à jouer importants sont en général
les gens les plus intelligents de france
mais ils sont un poil trop nombreux il
faudrait que j'en ai un petit peu moins
bien c'est juste pas beaucoup moins un
peu moins que vous par exemple
non mais moi je suis maintenant je suis
c'est pas pratique votre qu'un c'est
vraiment
[Musique]
donc je crois qu'il faut que l'attitude
des gens citoyens qui sont pas content
de la manière dont ça se passe je crois
pas qu'il faut qu'ils se réfugient sur
l'abstention disons plus ça m'intéresse
pas j'en ai marre je vois tu ce concret
où ils sont contents ils votent pour le
parti qu'ils ont choisie ou sont pas
contents il faut que ce pays reste un
pays vivant dynamique gérer attendait et
ils viennent comme moi j'ai fait faire
de la politique
la région m'intéresse pourquoi parce que
quelque part d'abord la situation de
cette région
c'est dommage on va pas parler de tout
ça sauf si la voiture balai qu'il est
aussi quelque part une voiture ils
arrivent derrière les autres bon me
parle un peu de choses sérieuses comme
non ils arrivent à saint-albain droit et
la france à l'europe la gauche la droite
rageuse pensais qu'on allait parler de
trucs on y vient bien sûr alors je jeudi
qu' aujourd'hui l'important c'est que
plein de gens des plombiers des médecins
des avocats des journalistes
plein de gens viennent rejoindre la
classe politique donc je retiens sans
être des proches des siennes en algérie
tient que vous avez en vue la région
vous avez dit ministre non parce que
c'est un boulot à temps plein donc un
boulot à temps plein ou cissé président
de la république dont ça c'est pas dans
votre chambre d'ambition non plus ni de
vision mais pourtant il faut une
candidature présidentielle alors que
vous avez et vous êtes arrivé d'évoquer
une candidature présidentielle oui ou
non je suis content là je vais prendre
cinq minutes
à ces cinq minutes de trois minutes on
en fait moi plaisir et puis soudain on a
le temps un peu y avait deux patrons de
chaînes là tout ça on peut faire cinq
minutes de plus vous dire c'est dit oui
moi je suis venu qu'une fois donc il
faut qu'on en profite on se verra pas
tous les jours un si quelque part
moi qui ne connais pas tapie je suis à
bayonne
je suis cadre supérieur et je lis les
journaux et je connais tapis par ce
biais là je vous faire une confidence
il me sortirait par les narines d'abord
parce que je trouve qu'il en fait des
tonnes ça c'est ce qui m'avait semblé
après ce que je dis je le dise ce type
il pourrait peut-être en faire un peu
moins que ça serait pas mal d'autre part
à plusieurs reprises j'ai eu le
sentiment qu'il avait un peu les plombs
qui son père mais je crois qu'il est
retenu
voilà ce que moi cadre au crédit
agricole à bayonne je pense de table
pourquoi ai je vais prendre justement ce
qui a été évoqué ya pas très longtemps
l'événement du jeudi fait un sondage
présidentiel il est appuyé dans le
sondage sort tapis 40 ch pourquoi
connerie parce que le sondage par les
élections
mais ça ça la même semaine le nouvel obs
voit que le sondage sort chez les
concurrents
car on commente des tapis pourquoi pas
et tant pis si tapie moi j'ai toujours
pas je n'ai pas ouvert je suis toujours
comme le glas bayonne le nouvel obs fait
la couverture prend pompidou coupe la
tête
mais ma tête bien en plus les chartes ou
bien layton je vous dis dès le pied quoi
tout le complet comme on dit à 6 pages
pour expliquer pourquoi pourquoi pas à
l'effet s'y est fait là et c est une
page avec monsieur julien que j'ai
beaucoup apprécié d'ailleurs à ce jour
là parce qu'il y avait bien changé
d'avis sur la veille changé d'avis il
fait partie des rares gentili je m'étais
trompé hélas une pose la question et je
vous explique pourquoi c'est ridicule et
nouvel obs fait le titre tapie l'homme
qui veut être président alors si moi je
suis à bayonne je vois quand je prends
mon avion pour aller à new york
le sondage l'événement du jeudi 5 pages
jean nouvel os cette espèce de
en première page comme ça avec bon mais
s'attendait en scène moi c'est le
magicien
moi ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est rien du
tout ça m'intéresse de savoir c'est un
point en mai c'est un jeu dans lequel on
ne peut pas échapper
et c'est pas la faute comme ça ce qui
m'intéresse à voir c'est injuste un
point précis c est ce qu à un moment ou
un autre vous envisageriez et pour
quelles raisons d'être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle ça veut pas ça
veut pouvoir dire
pour y figurer pour y mener un combat
pour y témoigner bon si vous laissiez le
temps de résoudre a expliqué pourquoi je
fais de la politique
quelque part je vais vous dire mais je
préférais vous répondu à cette je vous
réponds je pense que président de la
république c'est forcément une ambition
qui doit pas d'être à 40 ans c'est une
ambition qui ne peut être que le
résultat d'un militantisme depuis qu'on
a 20 ans d' d'un parcours politique ça
veut dire on a fait son apprentissage ça
veut dire qu'on a été un moment donné
dans la structure de l'état on a été
ministre on a géré en quelque sorte on a
montré qu'on était apte à exercer le
pouvoir
quand vous êtes un représentant de
seconde chose mais pas ça moi j'ai
montré que j'étais démerde que je
pouvais faire de chômeurs pour en faire
des jeunes qui avaient un boulot j'ai
montré et je vais montrer qu'on peut
réduire le pen à moins de 10% pourrait
le voir j'ai pas montré que j'étais
capable de connaître les mécanismes de
l'état
j'ai pas montré que j'étais capable
d'être un bon ministre j'ai pas montrer
tout ça si un jour je le montre j'ai le
temps j'ai 47 ans finalement j'ai encore
20 ans devant moi pour un jour avoir d
inspiration ou pour avoir des ambitions
mais c'est pas le cas pour l'instant les
ambitions c'est le pen - 10 c'est la
france qui va rentrer dormir chez eux
mais il faut qu'elle soit bien faut
qu'elle soit heureuse fou qu'elle sème
et puis d'autre part c'est un moment
donné cette région là elle est fabuleuse
elle est malheureuse en ce moment elle
est en train de mourir alors qu'elle est
fabuleuse c'est celle qui est la vitrine
sur la méditerranée la les belles c'est
là bien cette région là je veux mettre à
son service parce que je crois qu'elle a
un grand destin après on verra
sans après si on verra quand un patient
de répondre aux questions d'albert du
roi mais juste encore un mot parce que
je voudrais que vous nous éclairer mais
d'un mot sur la nature de vos relations
avec françois mitterrand je pose cette
question parce qu'il se trouve que
vous-même bernard tapie et françois
mitterrand vous avez le même conseiller
en communication parquet le hasard ou
par les saisir quelque chose je certifie
que j'ai pas de conseiller en
communication vous en avez eu pour la vo
campagne électorale tout de même écoutez
j'ai un tas d'avis parmi lesquels il ya
deux personnages attendent et permettez
moi qu ils sont les ce même pas les
conseils en un qui est maintenant par
exemple loto une fois qu'on y est
mais déjà qu'il en est et gérard collet
appelons-les par leur non plus à part
que mes deux sont avec lui quand il y en
a trois en général y en a qui disent
jamais son nom donc c'est des vrais
copains assez des vrais amis et moi il
me conseille pas pourquoi parce que moi
je considère peut faire la politique
avec des conseillers en marketing c'est
avoir dix ans de retard sur les réalités
et les besoins d'aujourd'hui vous voulez
je vous donne un exemple quand je vends
des piles monsieur des piles je raisonne
pas marketing en termes de parts de
marché car quand vous remarquerez que le
petit lapin qui durent plus longtemps
quand il continue de marcher que le
petit lapin qui n'en a pas les bonnes il
s'arrête
vous avez remarqué que le lapin qui
marche et pour le petit lapin par la
main pour le faire marcher avec lui le
marketing prévoit pas sa marque peut que
tignes prévoir quelle est la part de
marché comme on l'investît si on
permettait ce les hommes politiques
faisait un peu moins de marketing et un
peu plus de temps si cité va peut-être
que des gens comme pile en écho les
serait plus à l'aise car vous savez ce
qui donnerait il donnerait le message de
leur coeur et non pas le message de
leurs sondages et de leurs études car il
se fait que moi je les connais en tant
qu'homme et en tant qu'homme il va
largement au dessus que ce que valent
des conseillers en communication et
marketing
je vous le dis bien merci de mercy
jaunir accord avec les maires rapport
avec le président abbaoui et m'a demandé
est alors je ferai part à ça
maintenant mes rapports avec le
président ce sont elles que sur mon
honneur pas une seule fois il m'a dit
j'aimerais que vous fassiez et pas une
seule fois je lui ai demandé
je voudrais faire qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais rapports sont elles qui
m'appelle après et qui me dit c'est bien
ce que vous avez fait une fois il m'a
appelé pour me dire c'est pas facile de
m'épater en politique c'est après mon
élection dans une circonscription qui
était résolument à droite pour ne pas
dire à l'extrême droite
il m'a dit on n'a pas souvent épaté en
politique mais vous m'avez épaté quelque
part ça m'a rendu un peu fier du travail
que j'avais fait bien bon cette fois-ci
vous pouvez y aller titus svp geneviève
moll question mais c'était pis puisque
vous êtes très préoccupé par votre
région
est ce que vous êtes décidé à aider les
chantiers de la ciotat sont les
chantiers navals bien sûr bon les
sentiers de la ciotat ont un projet
actuellement c'est un projet d'un d'une
compagnie étrangère qui défend lexmark
wii qui défend la thèse selon laquelle
on peut refaire à la ciotat des
chantiers navals
moi je défend la thèse selon laquelle on
ne peut pas et on ne peut pas dans
l'état actuel parce que la concurrence
étrangère ne nous amène pas à la
possibilité de pouvoir faire des bateaux
au prix de revient un concurrentiel sans
l'aide de l'état et que l'état n'a a
décidé que c'était plus la priorité
absolue parce qu'il ya un chantier naval
l'atlantique qui est déjà difficile
je souhaite me tromper puisque
maintenant le conseil général a pris la
décision de faire en sorte que c'est la
société lexmark est en charge des
chantiers de la sauter mais s'ils se
sont trompés il faut savoir que les
employés de cette société ne seront pas
laissés pour compte car on reprendra ce
moment là le projet tel que nous
l'avions prévu et on fera des bateaux de
moins grande importance mais qui font
pas appel aux aides publiques pour
pouvoir exister
voilà actuellement sur le plan du droit
c'est la société lexmark
alors on enchaîne maintenant avec albert
du roy avec lequel vous allez traiter
tous les sujets qui
pas encore été traitée albert durant un
quart d'heure maximum non pas en un
quart d'heure en heure ça va sinon le
contrat sera pas remplie je voudrais
revenir à votre millefeuille de tout à
l'heure le millefeuille de l'extrême
droite
bon laissons de côté le premier étage
les gens qui sont faciste extrême droite
et cetera passons au deuxième et au
troisième qui sont plus intéressants
c'est à dire je rappelle ceux qui
s'estiment à tort ou à raison victimes
de la présence d'immigrés en france et
ceux qui s'estiment à trois raisons
encore victime de la crise de la
difficulté des temps etc
et commençons par ces derniers c'est à
dire c'est le problème des inégalités
alors avant de vous interroger sur un
certain nombre de choses précises de
projets précis évoqué en ce moment
d'abord ça peut étonner des gens que le
milliardaire que vous êtes françois
henri bour le rap est tout à l'heure
avec le côté un peu dallas impitoyable
le côté fric côté l'homme qui aime
l'argent se préoccupe de ce genre de
choses en une minute et demie comment ça
se fait
essayez commencer je fais un métier je
fais un métier d'abord je suis issu
vraiment d'un milieu très pauvre pas pop
répond et on enseigne un certain nombre
de choses et je suis pas bien je suis
pas bien dans ce milieu non pas parce
que je trouve que les règles morales qui
existent sont déplaisantes non pas parce
que j'y connais pas le bonheur parce que
je suis pas heureux de voir mon père
soumis aux autorités et du savoir et aux
autorités de l'argent car ce sont
souvent les mêmes mais des fois ce sont
pas les mêmes je suis tenté non mais moi
je peux aussi obligé de vous dire vous
allez raconter votre vie mais je le
patron le patron que vous êtes devenu
beaucoup plus tard il a été vous ne
faisait valley a répété salariés
vis-à-vis des salaires dérisoires et
priscilla on vous explique d'une
brutalité extraordinaire jamais mais que
vous pourrez pas faire l'économie des
trois minutes qui vous permettront de
comprendre où vous ne posez pas la
question où on fait pas grave je vous la
pose et je leur répondrai mais l on
arrive directement à ceux qui me livre
aux lèvres et range échapperait pas
cette plaque là mais je suis obligé de
vous dire comment car vous me parler des
inégalités ont parlé de ça 1
les inégalités de l'argent ça
représentait quelque chose
d'insupportable
mais à la limite j'en étais pas
malheureux figurez vous car j'avais
suffisamment d'affection avec mes
parents pour ne pas envier la belle
bagnole ou la télé qu'on n'avait pas il
ya une chose qui elle me faisait
souffrir
c'est l'autorité du médecin devant mon
père c'est l'autorité de l'ordre établi
devant mon père qui parlait pas le flic
compris par les pas mon père comme il
parlait aux gars qu'ils avaient une
belle bagnole et l'attitude de mon père
face à cette autorité là me faisait
souffrir car souffrait pas d'un manque
d'argent
je souffrais comprennent pas mon père en
considération et qu'on me prenne pour un
rien du tout parce que j'avais nil
savoir ni l'argent v6 avantgarde vous
avez pris votre revanche la primaire
dont j'ai dit ça sera pas comme ça pour
toutes les générations qui viennent
c'était pas une revanche sur qui n'ont
société elle est organisée comme ça
c'est pas moi qui les fait c'est pas un
régime particulier qui le fait c'est un
constat monsieur et j'ai décidé
petit à petit en suivant mes études en
faisant de la musique en faisant du
sport de sortir un peu
de la catégorie dans laquelle j'étais
j'y suis arrivé j'ai fait ensuite un
métier dont l'argent est le symbole de
vous avez réussi vous en faites un autre
l'écrivain quand il a un prix nobel
c'est comme ça qu'on matérialise sa
réussite on dit c'est un bon écrivain il
a un prix nobel
un journaliste qui est un de ceux qui
interview à l'heure de vérité on dit
c'est un journaliste qui a réussi la
chef d'entreprise qui a ruiné
c'est un chef d'entreprise karaté
figurez vous et comme je suis chef
d'entreprise et que j'ai réussi j'ai de
l'argent
l'article 1 j'ai de l'argent et je suis
cet article 2 je dis pas qu'en tant que
chef d'entreprise j'ai ma conscience
tranquille tous les jours pour deux
raisons parce que tous les jours je fais
pas des choses bien et puis parce que je
peux même pas moi me réfugier derrière
la hiérarchie des compétences la
hiérarchie des valeurs pour dire la
hiérarchie des gens vous savez pourquoi
parce que mon grand père paternel avait
autant de qualités que moi il était
aussi courageux il est aussi intelligent
il est aussi talentueux seulement lui il
a dit je mets tout ça au service des
autres il était le patron des syndicats
cgt de la sncf au bourget et moi j'ai
utilisé ses qualités pour m'enrichir
personnellement et pour faire que ma
famille vivent dans l'opulence je dis
pas que je suis heureux de ça et
peut-être que quelque part si je me suis
lancé dans ce combat le pen c'est
peut-être pour faire plaisir à mon grand
père parce que c'est moi que je n'ai pas
épaté en réussissant je sais quand on
ferme une usine ya pas de quoi rouler
des mécaniques et de quoi être fier
seulement quand on est chef d'entreprise
là encore on est confronté à une réalité
vraie est ce que vous vous conduisez
bien parce que l'entreprise va vivre
est-ce que vous conduisez mal parce que
l'entreprise périclite et qu'est ce que
vous pensez quand vous devez en arrivant
dans une entreprise comme ça vous êtes
arrivé souvent licenciés je pense à ce
qu'on va sauver
je pense au projet d'entreprise qui va
permettre de le réengager une chose que
vous savez peut-être pas le seul à
jamais été décrites
toutes les entreprises ont retrouvé tout
sans une exception si je manque
londers toutes les autres ça fait plus
de 40 on retrouvé dans les deux ans plus
d'effectifs que lorsque je suis arrivé
avant les licenciements le problème
c'est de savoir si un médecin
il est prêt à se suicider parce qu'ils
vous coupe un bras dans la limite aussi
vous le coup pas vous mais c'est trop
facile de
cette espèce de procès d'intention de
l'affairiste qui licencient c'est pas ça
le vrai sujet le vrai sujet je défends
pas ma chapelle
je peux vous certifier cas pas un chef
d'entreprise au monde qui se réveille un
matin heureux en disant chouette
aujourd'hui je vais en virée sans ça
n'existe pas il y en a pas un seul à
chaque fois qu'il est obligé de procéder
à une restructuration
comme c'est le cas dans les entreprises
nationalisées ou on a mis pourtant des
gens qui apparemment ont du coeur
puisqu'ils sont mis dans une boîte
nationaliser parce qu'ils sont de
sensibilité de gauche
ils font pareil parce qu'ils ont la
responsabilité du devenir d'une
entreprise donc des gens qui sont dedans
le président de la république tout
récemment a dénoncé ceux qui gagnent de
l'argent en dormant
c'était son expression est ce que il
vous semble qu'il y a une
impatience une révolte légitime de la
part des salariés qui éventuellement
subissent la dureté du marché du travail
devant des financiers des hommes
d'affaires des riches pour reprendre un
terme simple qui gagnent de l'argent
sans le mériter et je connais plus
beaucoup de monde qui gagnent de
l'argent sans le mériter parce que
maintenant même en travaillant pas tous
les matins il faut déjà être un peu
astucieux pour en gagner mais je suis
d'accord avec cette analyse en faites ce
que vous dites et ce qui est vrai c'est
il ya des inégalités dans un pays qui
apparemment va mieux et est ce que c'est
compatible ou pas on peut parler des
salaires sur les inégalités car elles
sont fortes
quelqu'un qui gagne moins de 5000 francs
ou 5200 francs par mois
il peut difficilement comprendre qu'on
lui donne pas plus quand ils voient les
titres il y en a dans des comptes privés
non actuellement seuls doit être 6008 je
vais vous dire parce que comme je me
doutais que j'allais me demander ça
actuellement la moyenne des salaires les
plus bas à 7079 francs la moyenne des
salaires les plus bas voilà le salaire
double salaire de plus bas je vais vous
le dire que même vous passez la fiche
ses 6000 soit 6500 soin de francs alors
ça vous étonne pas séjour de ces gens là
attendez je finirai d'accord non mais on
a le temps je vous le rappelle l'instant
je râlais la question les inégalités je
voudrais vous répondre à ça ceux qui
gagnent pas beaucoup d'argent ont le
droit de dire mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
car en 81 tout le monde était était et s
était sincère ils ont dit on va réduire
les inégalités en 9 90
parait-il sont plus grande je voudrais
dire qu'elles sont plus grandes jusqu'en
je porte ce rectificatif
permettez moi on verra si l'histoire de
guérison 80 88 88 a maintenant vous
verrez que les compteurs sont selon le
même cercle son étude est en charge des
coûts et pas selon un autre institut
pauvre petit toute façon ça change pas
grâce aux meilleures pour quand il ya
deux millions et demi de personnes qui
travaillent pas on peut parler ligne
arrivée elle vrai sujet d'inégalités que
c'est celui là il y en a deux c'est
quand on est égale inégal devant le
savoir car on n'a pas la même chance que
les autres et deuxièmement quand on est
privés d'emploi car en dehors du manque
d'argent
on a là vraiment un manque d'identité un
angle d'existence tout simplement on a
l'impression de faire partie
des exclus et ce sujet là il est à
aborder avec toutes ses forces
moi personnellement j'essaie de
comprendre pourquoi il y en a 1 millions
qui sont pratiquement pas récupérable
dans l'emploi classique où il faudra
créer des emplois par l'intermédiaire
d'associations
car ils sont pas capables de se
retrouver demain dans une configuration
d'employés mais il ya un million et demi
de gens qui peuvent parmi eux toutes les
initiatives qu'on peut prendre moi j'en
ai pris une il y en a plein qui peuvent
en prendre d'autres dire simplement que
les inégalités elles vont être réduites
parce qu'on va prendre les riches on va
les tops pour faire payer sur les
pauvres
c'est un schéma ça fait toujours
beaucoup d'effet mais il y a deux
inconvénients d'abord ça marche pas et
deuxièmement c'est pas vrai prenons un
exemple concret sur ce point là
actuellement bon sur les grandes
fortunes
non non non non pas et je le paye pas
l'impôt rennais sait que nous avions des
certains qui sont contents qu'ils payent
leur arnaque ou même pas la générosité
gratuite 90% à droite ils payent pas ils
sont contre ne répondait pas si on le
faisait pas la question que je voulais
vous poser avant que vous répondiez à
une autre c est ce qu actuellement en
débat faut-il imposer plus fortement les
plus values immobilières boursière était
en fait ce qu'il faut faire
il faut faire en sorte que à un moment
donné vous donniez pas envie à tout le
monde de foot le camp ailleurs car
figurez vous que vous avez des
contraintes qui sont les contraintes et
liberté aux gens de faire leur argent là
où ils veulent alors je crois pas moi
ces lois là ce que je crois par contre
c'est qu'il n'y a pas un chef
d'entreprise il n'y a pas un capitaliste
et par quelque part sensible qui est pas
quelque part désireux de faire que ça
marche bien car au deuxième degré
gagnera plus d'argent donc ce que je
crois moi c'est d'accepter de faire
rentrer tout le système dans dans un
dans une façon de concevoir les choses
plus généreuse je prends un exemple
est-ce qu'il est intelligent à long
terme de se faire des investissements
dans des pays étrangers
est-ce qu'il ait pas plus intelligent
d'essayer de rendre nos compétences nos
entreprises plus compétitives en france
quitte à ce qu'après ce soit celle la
paix
produisons france est un slogan
communiste il ya quoi une 7,8 en disant
mais alors moi je crois dit que tout ce
qui est de conduire les communistes
c'est à acheter je veux que je veux que
vibrer devant le tournoi des cinq
nations pour que la france gagne mais je
veux que la ménagère à qualité de
produit égal à prix égal elles donnent
une petite préférence les allemands le
font les anglais le fond vous sec pour
vendre un produit dans un hypermarché
allemand il faut être très très meilleur
marché où beaucoup beaucoup plus
performant alors vous pouvez donc je
voudrais que les gens agissent pareil je
vous pratiquez sur les produits ce que
d'autres appellent sur les hommes la
préférence nationale
est-ce qu'il faut régénérer qu'avoir un
jugement sur un paquet de lessive
annonce à la même profondeur d'esprit et
dames de leur jugement sur un individu
moi je veux bien vous êtes kelly notre
argent malir d'emploi vous êtes contre
la préférence ce qu'on appelle la
préférence à l'événement d'abord parce
que c'est ridicule c'est totalement
ridicule ça n'a pas de sens on juge les
gens par leur compétence par leur savoir
faire
cette priorité à allah pas de sens c'est
ça correspond à rien par rapport à ce
que je viens de vous dire sur le
comportement du consommateur alors en
deux mots peut-être si on n'a pas un peu
de temps comment jugez vous
vos confrères patrons et des jets skis
sont comme on le dit souvent trop
frileux pas assez nos patrons les
nouveaux patrons c'est quoi les nouveaux
c'est ce qu'on appelle les chefs
d'entreprises par rapport à avant on
appelait ça des patrons maintenance et
des chefs d'entreprise c'est d'ailleurs
ce sont des gens qui font un métier qui
sont pas de droit divin qui prennent en
considération les revendications des
gens qui sont très attentifs au cercle
de qualité qui font qu'il ya des
promotions qui font qu'en en quelque
sorte ils ont compris une chose monsieur
c'est qu'on viendrait concilier le
profit avec l'intérêt collectif vous
savez pourquoi
parce que maintenant il n'y a plus
d'ambiguïté les sociétés dont les
avancées sociales sont les plus fortes
sont celles qui gagnent le plus d'argent
ça me revient à la pensée du coeur tout
à l'heure c'est dire aux chefs
d'entreprise ayez du coeur
c'est un mode de gestion pas forcément
durable mais dites leur soyez chesnais
rue avec votre personnel vous gagnerez
plus de fric
vous verrez que c'est quand même plus
certain
donc vous êtes de gauche parce que ça
marche alors ça c'est sûr que c'est mon
avis je suis de gauche parce que c'est
ça qui va marcher
pas parce que je me prêtant plus utopie
plus rêveurs plus généreux plus
solidaire jeudi contre une société gérée
selon un mode de relation
promu par la sensibilité nouvelle gauche
a toutes les chances de réussir bien
mieux parce qu'elle prend vraiment en
considération chacun que celles qui
croient que c'est parce qu'on va être
très brillant très performant et que par
conséquent il y aura de la richesse
qu'on pourra faire face aux besoins des
banques je voudrais qu'on n'a pas parlé
d'europe s'épouvante un vrai qu'on
puisse dire un mot
de l'autre étage du millefeuille en ce
qui concerne les immigrés joueurs
d'accord sur les immigrés est-ce que la
nécessité de l'intégration à laquelle
vous faisiez lisant tout à l'heure
est-ce que la nécessité de l'intégration
va à votre avis jusqu'à faire des
immigrés en situation régulière
évidemment des citoyens dans leurs
villes dans leur département c'est à
dire ce qu'il faut leur donner leur
droit de vote le droit de vote la
première question c'est pas celle là la
première question c'est de dire un pays
comme la france à des immigrés
je n'ai vu encore nulle part qu elle l
achat quel est le contrat ou morale ou
juridiques et morales qui relie
l'immigré au pays qu'est la france
c'est à dire quelles sont ses vrais
droits et quelles sont ses vrais de voir
ça pourrait être un nouveau code de
nationalité à l'inter pourquoi pas à
l'intérieur des immigrés en situation
irrégulière
moi je veux savoir quels sont ceux qui
sont prêts à se plier aux règles et
usages de mon pays qui les accueille et
on leur dira ce moment là quels sont les
droits qu'ils sont la possibilité
d'atteindre mais il ya quand même des
choses qui me chiffonne c'est vrai que
sur les 20 derniers milles recensé
jeunes en âge faire leur service
militaire il y en a que cinq mille ans
choisi de faire leur service militaire
en france il y en a six mille camp
dans leur pays d'origine et y en a dix
mille qui sont arrangés pour pas faire
de service militaire du tout donc moi je
veux dire à mon pays et un monte mes
concitoyens on n'a pas le droit de se
comporter avec autant de mépris pour les
émigrés que ce que certains nous propose
de faire on n'a pas le droit c'est pas
notre intérêt et en plus c'est pas comme
ça qu'on a été conçu ce sont pas les
valeurs qu'on nous a inculqué mais
n'importe qui n'a pas le droit de faire
n'importe quoi et ceux qui viennent chez
moi chez vous doivent se plier à nora
usage car son nom revient sinon à ce que
je vous dit à l'heure est raciste celui
qui dit il et escrocs mais les noirs
donc il est bien non monsieur un noir il
est noir
qui saura si c'est un escroc et à
l'escroc si c'est un type bien c'est un
type bien
c'est pareil pour les immigrés je fais
pas de complexes mois à nîmes y en
situation régulière et qui fait du
boulot noir il prive la société dans son
organisation d'un équilibre qui va la
rendre inévitablement insupportable je
lui demande de [ __ ] le camp
c'est sûr et certain si par contre il
est en mesure d'assurer ce que j'ai
besoin qu'il assure
c'est à dire sa présence sa culture sa
complémentarité
son originalité est qu'ils se plient à
nos rêves qui se plient à nos usages
dont elle a besoin lui c'est ce qui va
faire notre originalité à un moment où
on va rentrer dans l'europe car on va y
aller dans l'europe et moi plus on me
parle de l'europe que jean d'enjeux dont
j'entends les échos et plus à me fout la
trouille et - exalte pour l'instant donc
il va bien falloir que je refasse
l'inventaire de mes vraies munitions à
moins de vrais de mais vraie originalité
de mes plus les europe l'europe où j'ai
peur comment et comment elle me fait
peur aujourd'hui elle ne fait peur
j'étais un de ceux qui étaient le
premier emballé je dis ça être
formidable et ça continue pour moi
d'être un projet formidable fait d'abord
on me répond en hypermarchés
trop souvent on me répond c'était des
supermarchés formidable ça va être un
hypermarché grandiose ça quelque part
dans fout un peu alors c'est pas ça qui
m'exalte deuxièmement moi j'ai envie
qu'on m'entende et qu'on apprécie pour
ce que je suis tel que je suis je veux
pas devenir un sou germanique
parce que ça me va pas bien la
suprématie de l'allemagne dans cette
europe réunifiée que souhaitable qui va
être une locomotive phénoménal il faut
que ce soit une locomotive phone mais
moi je veux pas être le wagon je veux
être une autre loupé ça vous dérange pas
parce que si je suis que le wagon
d'allemagne même si elle est formidable
je vais pas me sentir bien chez nous
donc j'ai envie d'être une autre locaux
alors je fais la langue dans l'autre
sens oui non mais
vous en faites pas des wagons il y en
avoir quelques reins attirer et là j'ai
eu droit à une dernière question se
donne un petit pour le titre et rien à
voir avec ce qui précède
l'un deux de vos collègues
co-actionnaires de tf1 jean-louis
pétriat patron de la gmf et serra a
quitté tf1 pour parce que ça lui
déplaisait que les programmes ne lui
plaisait pas et de tera est ce que vous
êtes tentés de faire la même chose il il
n'a pas bien fait ce qu'il a fait
d'abord parce que ça ne se fait pas j'ai
rien des choses justement quand on
défend des valeurs et il défend des
valeurs
en tout cas il prétend défendre des
valeurs pour moi quand on est patron des
gmf on est forcé de représenter ces
valeurs-là et des choses qui ne se font
pas et on n'a pas le droit de mettre sur
la place publique une attitude qui peut
faire généré en tout cas des conflits
faites bien de parler de la télévision
je veux dire pourquoi télévision c'est
un des sujets dans tout le monde parle
et ses sujets sur lequel tout le monde a
un avis or c'est une des activités les
plus difficiles au monde que je
connaisse il faut sauvegarder plusieurs
choses et pour l'instant c'est
sauvegarder qu'elles soient privées ou
publiques
je crois que jamais vous journalistes
vous avez joué d'autant de liberté
d'action d'actes et de paroles ça faut
quand même le dire parce que c'est le
plus important
tous vos confrères de tout le monde
entier vous envie pour ça ensuite on
fait un débat public contre privé
c'est une énorme connerie c'est ce que
c'est la télévision
c'est à la tête il ya quelqu'un de
talentueux et la télévision marche on a
vu sans arrêt passé là une devant la
deûle à 2 devant la une à une devant la
207 et public
vous pouvez vous m'en donnez actes parce
que de temps en temps le pdg de l'homme
était meilleur que la deux et ça
devenait le contraire il ya une nouvelle
disposition des ducs a été donnée
laisser le temps au temps
il faut que la nouvelle direction ne
rende fasse la démonstration qu'elle est
capable dans un premier temps de ramaré
et deuxièmement de battre la une et sur
le tapis
qu'on cesse de mettre mon niveau casser
le matériel à deux c'est pas là de cela
il est resté qu'on cesse de mettre en
parallèle d'un côté les émissions
insignifiante à forte audience et d'un
autre côté les émissions qui ont pas
d'audience mais qui sont intelligentes
pour faire des émissions à forte
audience
vous êtes vous bien faut qu'elle soit un
peu intelligente ou alors c'est que vous
prenez les français pour des contres ils
sont pas plus cons que vous n'y que moi
c'est pas le cas dans cette émission nom
viendrait fait pas beaucoup d'audience
hier merci merci albert ii roi
on verra ça demain merci albert du roy
mais il ya quand même un peu plus d'une
heure qu'on parle et il ya une de vos
usines qui est en grève qui est en grève
depuis une semaine et on en a pas dit un
mot [ __ ] parce que les jours dans les
journaux n'en parlent pas et chose qui
s'en sortent et 20 semaines
oui enfin grand chose à ses jours ne
semblent pas pourquoi deux choses oui à
gicquel comment vous réagissez comme
hier ça qui était dans la semaine juste
avant l'heure de vérité il ya des fois
on n'a pas de chance deux choses sont
sûres l'histoire de votre avion il en
attribue de l'expansion de ce matin mais
votre usine d'engrais et voilà les uns
sûrement de bonnes raisons mais on a une
zone reste des raisons salariales
la moyenne des salaires chez eux et 7079
francs c'est une boîte qui a été reprise
en faillite en mai 87
les augmentations de salaires au cours
des trois dernières années a été de 21%
je regrette ne pas leur donner plus mais
ça m'amène en fait à conclure que oui
c'est pas seulement que l'argent qui
fait le bonheur puisque ces gens là sont
mis en grève
je peux pas croire que la cgt était
animée du désir de semer tendresse juste
avant cette émission ça peut pas exister
dos je crois qu'en fait l'argent fait
pas toujours le bonheur et il va falloir
qu'on écoute ces gens qu'on soit
attentifs à ce qu'ils ont à me dire
car ils se sont mis en grève pour qu'on
se rencontre et on va se rencontrer dès
lundi je pourrais pas donné beaucoup
plus que 7 me soit parce que le jour où
le smic sera déjà faits tels chiffres
7079 en attendait ce qui fait un seul
adrian 7120 alors c'est pas y'a pas de
quoi à chanter mais 21% de migration
trois ans vous voyez que l'argent fait
pas toujours le bonheur puisqu'ils sont
pas plus mal payés et avant n'est pas
brillé et pourtant non la cdas aucune
c'est un c'est un avion que nation à une
situation de monopole qui les rend de
temps en temps un peu maladroit et
beaucoup prétentieux c'est pas une
réponse beaucoup prétentieux bon c'est
pas tout à fait une réponse
nous passons belge précise que les
usines en question ses usines de
casseroles automne une casserole
voilà
glem l usine de casseroles la voilà
regardez nous ne votons non respect pour
3 toute petite question madame barzakh a
proposé pour stopper ou enrayer
l'épidémie de sida
la réouverture des maisons closes qu'en
pensez vous
franchement je suis ni habitués des
maisons ouvertes ni habitués des maisons
closes
moi je crois qu'il faut simplement
prendre la précaution de mettre un
préservatif
que ce soit dans une maison close ou
dans une maison ouverte dans la limite
où de toute façon personne n'est à
l'abri et comme c'est pas marqué sur la
tête
sauf de se promener avec son dernier
bulletin de santé et je crois encore qui
a une durée de gestation tels que
franchement je vais vous dire ma façon
de penser
on peut éventuellement faire une société
sans bordel quelque part donc je madame
barzakh à la des préoccupations qui sont
pas les miennes et sont politiques
que pensez vous de la position d'alain
carignon en ce qui concerne les
élections à villeurbanne il avait mon
amitié il a mon admiration
dernière question on n'a pas du tout
parlé de carpentras que pensez-vous de
la publicité qu'on a fait le tour
il faut attendre la suite pour savoir si
on a bien fait de la faire ou pas mais
c'est ce jour là que j'ai compris qu'on
voulait nous classés en deux catégories
d'un côté les racistes d'un autre côté
les non raciste et moi je vais vous dire
je suis pas allé dans les synagogues ce
week-end là on m'a demandé pourquoi et
j'ai répondu parce que là il n'y a pas
d' antisémite est en fait tout ce qu'ils
peuvent pas supporter qu'il ya des
antisémites il faut qu'il fasse comme
moi vous savez comment j'ai fait à
marseille je vous racontais ça il faut
que ça reste entre nous j'ai pris un
camion location sur lequel j'ai mis un
plateau avec un micro et des éclairages
et je suis allé dans une cité où le pen
avait fait 57 % des suffrages
et là j'ai parlé de 7h à 9h du soir au
milieu de la cité
le candidat du front national a fait
quatre et demi pour cent aux mêmes
élections législatives ça veut dire que
finalement c'est pas en faisant de la
télévision ni en là en allant un jour où
tout le monde est ému de bonne foi h par
se ressembler se rassembler dans la rue
je crois qu'il faut faire un travail de
proximité que les partis politiques font
plus et que le cas là ce sont bien les
écoles dans les usines dans les cités
vous y trouvez des gens du front
national
on y trouve plus les gens du rpr on y
trouve plus les socialistes on y trouve
à peine d comme
et si on veut gagner ce combat de la
proximité ce combat de la conviction
c'est en allant là c'est en leur disant
oh du bouche à oreille non pas par la
télévision
on peut plus continuer à faire une
politique où toute la base militante
apprend les lignes du parti en regardant
la télévision
il faut que quelque part on redonne
envie aux gens de militer quand on était
gosses tous autant que vous êtes
on pensait tous cas ça il y avait des
démobilisations formidable on était prêt
à s'emballer on travaillait ont collé
des affiches on avait quelque part une
envie de croire à des choses
aujourd'hui on l'a plus on a laissé au
front national cette possibilité de
capitaliser l'ensemble de cette
potentialité de militants donc il faut
retrouver ça voilà c'était donc l'heure
de vérité de bernard tapie nous allons
maintenant signer le livre d'or
bonsoir
[Musique]